let's see here let's go to Papa let's go
to the 408 area code who's calling it
from 408 today hey david kaynor me
yeah I can't who's this this is Jonathan
Chavez I'm I'm currently I'm from I'm
from San Jose right now I'm living in
San Diego cool we're calling from
technically but uh I just have a
question I know this is kind of like a
random but I just wanted to see your
opinion on it
have you ever read the works of Karl
Marx and do you believe there's an e or
a more ragged ization at the left in the
United States okay so I see those as two
are they two separate questions or is it
the same one or is it part of the same
one um you know they are more like okay
all right I mean I'm not saying that
sarcastically I just mean are you saying
like do I agree with Marx on that issue
I read Marx during my time studying
economics undergrad so that's been a
little while at this point I haven't
since beyond essays about Marx's
teachings but I read Marx directly
translated obviously when I was an
undergraduate at the University of
Massachusetts so as far as this the left
how did you frame it does the left need
to become more radical in in order to do
something in particular oh I mean yeah I
think I mean in my opinion or my belief
I think we need to move away from
capitalism itself so I suppose if if you
actually believe I know you kind of more
of a social democrat so I know maybe you
don't but right maybe like overall maybe
we might believe that having more
radicalized left might help in that way
at least do it okay good this is an
excellent question so the term
radicalized is maybe where we would have
a like a semantic or a subjective
disagreement I think that unless further
left ideas become mainstreamed we are
not going to move the debate to the left
so this is like one of the main
accomplishments of Bernie's 2016
candidacy was that he mainstreamed the
ideas of Medicare for all
tuition free college not that it was his
idea but he talked about it a lot
and transaction taxes and higher
marginal tax rates on top earners etc
etc now that that has been mainstreamed
there's an opportunity for an even
further left sort of idea to start
pulling the Overton Window more and more
to the progressive side I don't think
that we need a strong Stalinist
presence in the United States political
milieu in order to become more social
socially democratic the way I would like
to see so I think that yes we need more
mainstreaming of further left ideas but
I don't know that we benefit from having
really untenable and and getting into
more of the authoritarian leftism I
don't think social democracy benefits
from that type of radicalization oh I
got you
well it doesn't necessarily have to be
authoritative we'll give you an example
I mean so like ok let's talk let's let's
put the rubber on the road so to speak
what sort of radical left ideas would
you like to see more mainstreamed in the
American left well I would definitely
think that if we kind of need to move
towards thinking about these ideas not
in terms of how we saw in the Soviet
Union because obviously there is there's
a lot of problems in Soviet Union in
order to you know implement socialism
there however it doesn't necessarily
mean that we need to actually go through
this crazy you know you know
militaristic transition in order to get
there we can they can do this you know
through through policy and by educating
the public little by little and having
us eventually transition over into um
you know a socialist economy today I
because I personally believe that there
really isn't going to be a choice
eventually that the system is not going
to survive as it is ok so who do you how
do you imagine the transition happening
and who do you think in what way would
we advocate for it in the political
discussion that happens on the left so I
mean I kind of take after the what
George Woolf has been nice and
advocating for more working co-ops you
know if a corporation would want to
leave or try to like outsource its um
its industry or whatever we can have a I
believe it's called the the right of
first refusal I think I think it's what
the policy is called the exactly works
instead of having you know we could have
the the employees who are could work in
the actual industry decide whether like
whether they'll they're okay with like
laying the the corporation leave all
right they can then or they can decide
to keep the corporation there or the
factory there or there's no jobs there
and then the government can then will
then buy out the actual factory in the
corporation or whatever and then they
can own it and work with themselves as
they worked co-op got it good okay so
you you sort of like promote the idea of
worker coops in the United States but at
certain point you said you want to move
to actual socialism which makes it you
can no longer have private business
ownership it's all social ownership of
businesses how do you make that
transition do you declare that private
business is no longer allowed well yeah
I mean so I mean I mean for me the
beginning part would be the more making
recall like making that site look like
institution more more like normal
among the other active working people
yep and then through that the court like
the culture of the whole like the way we
talk about like ownership will probably
change and you know I think more people
would probably be more more open to
socialized socialization or
nationalization and if we can keep like
and then we can keep democracy and had
that I see in fact it might be and
that's the most important thing is
inside this transition is that we the
decided the society needs to be
democratic in order for right but now
hold on so you said first you were
talking about socializing the means of
production then you said nationalizing
it which is different altogether but so
here we don't have to go back and forth
oh those are you different things the
important thing I would say is I'm
totally with you on the promotion of
coops and and everything else you're
talking about
know how you get to saying okay now no
private business ownership is allowed
and you can only have the co-op's that
sounds to me like it would require
authoritarianism to implement it but
it's probably a bigger a bigger
discussion I'm out of time so I've got
to let you go
a sorry to everybody I was not able to
get to you today but we'll take calls
again next week and I'll probably do
another stream soon and open up the
phone lines as well quick break back
after this